Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Quanto è bella la diretta, e la vita vera.
Non siamo più in quello
che abbiamo vissuto due anni fa,
dietro uno schermo.
Salve a tutti.
Sono qui felice, grato
e anche un po' emozionato -
parecchio emozionato -
per parlarvi del daimon,
della casa da dove tutti noi proveniamo
ed anche della possibilità di riconoscere
lo scopo della nostra vita,
o il progetto della nostra anima
prima della nascita.
Grande tema.
Quello che normalmente viene conosciuto
come "lo scopo della vita" -
mi domando: chissà quanti di voi
conoscono il proprio daimon,
e il proprio scopo nella vita?
Non vi chiedo di alzare la mano:
ma vediamo un po'.
Già nell'antica Grecia
era nota l'importanza
di riconoscere il nostro daimon,
e lo scopo della nostra vita.
Pensate che l'oracolo di Delfi,
nel tempio di Apollo,
accoglieva i suoi pellegrini
con questa frase:
"Ti avverto: chiunque tu sia,
o tu che desideri sondare
gli arcani della natura,
se non riuscirai a trovare
dentro te stesso ciò che cerchi,
non potrai trovarlo nemmeno fuori.
Se ignori le meraviglie della tua casa,
come pretendi di trovare altre meraviglie?
In te è celato il tesoro degli dei.
O uomo, "gnòthi seautòn":
conosci te stesso,
e conoscerai l'universo e gli dèi".
Tiro il fiato.
Dopo queste parole così altisonanti,
mi verrebbe da dirvi
che mi occupo di felicità,
di felicità degli esseri umani.
Ma in maniera molto più semplice,
vi dico che da oltre 30 anni
di ricerca su queste tematiche
ho scoperto un paio di cose
veramente interessanti
riguardo la felicità degli esseri umani.
Innanzitutto,
ho scoperto cosa ci impedisce
di godere pienamente della nostra vita
e della nostra felicità.
E poi ho scoperto un altro paio di cose:
che tutti noi, in qualsiasi modo,
cerchiamo una cosa sola:
cerchiamo la felicità.
Ciascuno di noi, a modo proprio,
indipendentemente dalla razza, dall'età,
dallo status sociale,
dall'economia, dalla cultura:
tutti noi cerchiamo la felicità.
L'unica cosa è che ciascuno
la cerca a modo proprio,
e non sempre quel modo
è veramente efficace e realizzante.
Per esplorare un po' di queste tematiche,
nei tanti anni di formazione
con le persone, nelle formazioni, ecc,
ho scoperto un paio di cose:
possiamo essere veramente sereni
quando agiamo in sintonia
e nel rispetto dei nostri valori.
Ma possiamo essere veramente felici
quando agiamo in accordo
con il nostro daimon,
di cui parleremo tra un attimo.
Quindi dobbiamo ancora fare
una piccola riflessione
prima di entrare
nell'archetipo del daimon,
ovvero: chi siamo noi?
Ci riteniamo degli esseri umani
che ogni tanto hanno uno sprazzo
di esperienza spirituale,
oppure siamo degli esseri spirituali
che stanno compiendo
un viaggio esperienziale,
qui sulla terra, in forma umana?
Fa una grande differenza.
Fin da piccoli ci hanno detto:
ma cosa vuoi fare da grande?
Ve lo ricordate?
In realtà, poche volte ci hanno chiesto:
ma cosa ti renderà felice?
E ancor meno ci hanno chiesto:
qual è lo scopo della tua vita?
Perché sei qui?
Cosa sei venuto a fare,
qui, in forma umana?
Domande a cui non è facile dare risposte.
Domande profonde, che sicuramente
ci siamo già fatti fin da bambini.
I bambini si fanno delle domande
di una grande profondità esistenziale:
ma non sempre trovano,
nei genitori o nei loro educatori,
qualcuno in grado
di sostenerli in questa ricerca.
Ma in realtà, forse,
non abbiamo nemmeno condiviso
questa nostra domanda,
perché per la cultura dominante
questa cosa può apparire un po' strana,
quasi un tabù, quasi un'utopia,
di cui non è il caso di parlare.
Per cui il tema è
che io in questo momento non ho l'idea
di proporvi una risposta preconfezionata,
ma piuttosto mi piacerebbe ispirarvi
a ritrovare quella domanda,
o magari a rimettervi in moto
per trovare quella risposta.
E se chiedessi a te -
sì proprio a te, o a te, o a te -
"Qual è lo scopo della tua vita?",
e ti chiedessi di condividerlo qui,
ora, davanti a tutti,
che cosa mi risponderesti?
Non preoccupatevi,
non vi faccio questa domanda:
ma piuttosto preferirei farvi notare
che quella domanda è ancora
qui con noi, in questo momento.
E vi prego di sentirla -
non di pensarla, di sentirla -
quanto la nostra anima
ancora vorrebbe riconoscere
il suo scopo in questa vita.
Vi condivido delle parole,
che amo molto, di Joseph Jaworsky,
un formatore che ha fatto molto evolvere
la formazione aziendale:
"Ho scoperto che le persone
non hanno veramente paura di morire;
hanno paura di non aver mai vissuto,
di non aver mai considerato a fondo
il vero scopo della loro vita,
di non essere mai entrati
in contatto con quello scopo
e avere almeno tentato di fare
la differenza in questo mondo".
Ci fa riflettere, è vero?
Ma se vogliamo un grande sostegno,
per esplorare questo tema,
possiamo attingere alle ricerche
di Carl Gustav Jung
e al prosecutore
della sua opera, James Hillman.
Nelle sue ricerche sul codice dell'anima,
ed anche sui suoi scritti,
troviamo degli spunti
davvero interessanti, per scoprire questo.
Hillman ci parla del daimon.
Questo daimon non è un demone,
ma un ente spirituale
che ci accompagna alla nascita,
e ce lo descrive benissimo
nell'ultimo capitolo
del "La Repubblica" di Platone,
dove descrive il mito di Er.
Er è questo eroe greco
che è caduto in battaglia,
e resuscita dopo dodici giorni.
E incontrando i suoi compagni d'arme,
racconta loro la sua
esperienza di premorte
ed anche d'aver visitato la dimensione,
e il mondo spirituale,
prima della nascita.
Molto interessante perché molti,
come Dante Alighieri,
ci raccontano del dopo la morte:
Er ci racconta del prima della nascita,
e ci dice che la nostra anima
sceglie il proprio destino.
Ma non come un fato
indefinibile, non modificabile;
ma come una direzione,
come una destinazione,
una traiettoria per scendere
dal mondo spirituale
ed entrare nella dimensione
che noi conosciamo,
questa della nostra vita vera.
Per farlo, però,
l'anima ha bisogno di essere incoraggiata
a tornare nei limiti umani,
ha bisogno di essere affiancata
e sostenuta da un daimon.
Un daimon è proprio un ente spirituale
che non solo ci consiglia,
ma ci esorta ad intraprendere
l'esperienza umana.
Perché?
Perché è la più grande possibilità
di accelerazione, di crescita,
di consapevolezza di sé.
L'anima, nelle prove della vita umana,
ha modo di conoscersi sempre più.
Ed è per questo che il daimon la sostiene
nell'individuare le corrette
condizioni di incarnazione:
come per esempio
nella famiglia di origine,
sembrerà strano;
il nostro corpo,
la sensibilità del nostro sistema nervoso,
in relazione all'evoluzione soggettiva,
diciamo.
Ed anche a scegliere determinati incontri
o eventi della nostra vita
che saranno determinanti
per la nostra evoluzione.
Quindi il daimon è fondamentale,
per questa scelta.
Però, c'è un però.
L'anima deve affrontare una grande prova:
varcare il fiume Lethe,
il fiume dell'oblio,
il fiume della dimenticanza,
dove dimentica la sua natura divina.
Ed ecco che si sente, poi,
smarrita nel mondo,
perché nel liquido amniotico,
non a caso il liquido dell'amnesia,
dove si dimentica la propria natura,
deve tornare nei limiti
della dimensione umana.
Ma perché?
Perché proprio nei limiti
della dimensione umana,
dove potrà sperimentare l'intensità
delle emozioni, dei sentimenti,
dell'amore e anche dell'odio.
Perché questa intensità
l'aiuterà a ritrovare se stessa.
Il tema è che l'anima, a questo punto,
si sente spersa, sola, vuota,
scollegata dall'intera esistenza;
e quindi il suo sforzo è di superare
quello che in psicologia viene chiamata
"la sofferenza esistenziale",
ovvero la sofferenza collegata
non a degli eventi precisi,
ma è quello che viene anche detto
"il male di vivere una vita senza senso".
Ecco perché è importante
riportare a galla la nostra domanda,
e chiederci appunto
qual è il senso della mia vita.
Ma non per fare cose grandiose,
ma fare ciò che realmente mi rende felice.
Ecco che per l'anima -
come ci avverte Viktor Frankl,
l'ideatore della logoterapia -
è importante permettersi di sentire
quella sofferenza esistenziale,
perché è energia che possiamo
ricondurre, riorientare,
verso il nostro sviluppo interiore.
Ed ecco che così potremo superare
tutta una serie di difficoltà
che a volte ci fanno trovare smarriti.
Concludo con un semplice ragionamento:
come sarebbe la percezione di noi,
e del mondo, e degli altri del mondo
se avessimo chiaro qual è
lo scopo della nostra vita?
E se fosse vero che abbiamo scelto
la nostra famiglia di origine,
e determinate situazioni
della nostra vita,
per fare evolvere la nostra anima
a livello spirituale?
E se fosse vero che quel daimon
che ci ha suggerito a fare questo
sia ancora qui, accanto a noi?
E talvolta interviene, anche,
nella sincronicità degli eventi -
come questo per esempio -
per ricordarci che forse è il caso
di riportare l'attenzione
allo scopo del perché siamo qua?
E se fossero vere le parole
di Osho, quando ci dice:
"Tu non sei affatto superfluo,
o privo di significato;
la tua presenza
è enormemente significativa.
Dunque ama te stesso.
Tu sei necessario qui
come lo sono gli alberi, i fiori,
gli uccelli, il sole, la luna, le stelle.
Tu devi essere qui
e hai il diritto di essere
esattamente così come sei."?
Concludo con questo pensiero:
e se fosse vero
che anche tu hai uno scopo esistenziale,
da realizzare in questa vita,
quale sarebbe?
Grazie.